どうもありがとうございました
こちらこそ！どうも有難うございました〜
来た
ね？
では。おやすみ。
あークレジットで
ありがとうございマックス村井
すみません、ありがとうございました～
はい、ありがとうございました
はい、
今日のメインチューン
落した！
後はあいつの家に電話するだけだ。今呼ぶ。
はい。
私だ
お願いします
失礼する
ミスった、ミスった
済まない、閉まってしまった。
行くぞ
お邪魔します
あ！　こわ！
ここが、たくみの部屋。？
僕の部屋です
部屋ですよね
あの、ちょっとお話しでは聞いてるんですけども
色々と怪奇現象というか、怪しいんだよね？
怪しいです
決して、この物件がどうこう言う話じゃないんですよ
純粋に彼が有った事と言うか
実際に会った事のみを話すので
悲しそうな顔になってる
恐くないとこから言ってもいい？
どうぞ、もう･・・
ちょっと、こっちなんだけど
もうですか？
早速ですか
玄関ね
靴箱って普通靴入れるじゃないですか
靴箱靴入れますね
僕、こんだけ全部ここに置いてあって
理由が、この下駄箱にあって、
下駄箱って普通、悪くて臭い・・・
まあ、確かに。
良くて、無臭・・・
はいはい
・・・が、ベストじゃないですか？
これ、最悪で
開けて臭い嗅いでください
ヤバくない？
もう一回いいっすか？
ちょっと待って・・・
ここのドア、見えます？
見てもらうと分かるんですけど
水滴みたいなのが着いた痕があるんですよ
確かに、見えるね
このドア・・・普通にこうなってるじゃないですか？
朝起きたり、外から帰って来たりすると大抵、
これが、こう、下向きになってるんですよ。結構な確率で
それをね、オイラ聞きたかったんだよ
って言うか、それを今回検証したかったんだですよね。
すっごい恐いんだけど
あれが勝手に下がるんでしょ？
我々は決してこの物件を自己物件ととか言おうとしてる訳じゃないんですよ
下がってる
ただ、この物件で、あった事を述べているだけ
何でもなってないんでしょう？
成ってなかった
成ってないんだったら
我々で調べるしかないだろうと言う事で
取りあえず、そこだね本当に